hey what's up I'm just a nerd I just
seem to spot a hen way what's the anyway
slap God
it's just dance with the braids in the
hair I was browsing on Pinterest somehow
an hour or two or three or four hours I
looked down and my hair was braided you
get it is there's a lot of braids on
Pinterest if you have to explain the
joke it's not a joke
oh honey my darkest fear I don't know
about my darkest fear my biggest fear is
having my teeth fall out whether I trip
or if somebody punches me and all of
them fall out I have nightmares all the
time where I'm just toothless no Emma I
am in no way shape or form a fan of
lobster I don't want my voices I'm gross
like this one they don't clean him well
like look at this look at this stuff oh
yeah to ever have to change a lightbulb
yes I have changed a lightbulb before
you start the blonde chips how many
bones does it take to change life all
but let me tell you why one changed by
myself Bob wants nope I will be buying
black ops 2 yeah I actually already
pre-ordered it all of November you guys
aren't even gonna see a video here
they're all gonna be on my gaming
channel I'm gonna be playing Halo and
Call of Duty it just non-stop what was
my favorite part about Minecraft those
of you guys who don't know I started a
minecraft server and probably my
favorite part is logging on and just
hanging out with you guys when I first
started the server there was a hundred
people digging me into a hole that was
actually probably my least favorite part
helped me take some minecraft questions
I saw you a comic-con hi how are you
doing what do I think of my world I
think it's absolutely amazing you guys
are so cool do I watch The Walking Dead
I do I absolutely love The Walking Dead
I'm half with your season two what's my
favorite type of dog
I love King Charles Spaniels I like red
vs. blue I love red vs. blue will I be
your friend yes I will be your friend
i'll what's minecraft like it's great
you're in the game um favorite marilyn
manson song the Beautiful People the
Beautiful People you guys are absolutely
awesome and I love this friggin game
haha look look who they made logo
there's a YouTube logo there's a star
there's a Mario all my goodness and the
best part there's an Apple logo we've
got a full-size freaking Steve Jobs
statue hell yeah
question well I think of the rumors of a
little iPad first thing that I think of
the rumors of a little iPad is a little
thing called iPhone what kind of sound
does draft make I hope that answers your
question
Noah wants to know are you a brownie or
a Pegasus source Pegasus sir I don't
know what that means
hey I hope it doesn't mean anything bad
following that question Jason
Channing Tatum or Josh Hutcherson I
don't know who Josh is so I have to go
with Channing right
nabil wants to know how I got into video
games to be completely honest with you
I've never not really been into video
games I had pretty much every Nintendo
up until well now Kenneth what's the
craziest thing I've ever done with my
hair but it's not really real
so yeah to be honest probably the
craziest thing that I ever thought
actually looked good was my super blonde
hair a couple years ago why didn't
nobody tell me that it looked like
absolute oh you did that's right cuz
that's the see internet you guys are
always very very honest comedians - yep
a sound coming if you guys would like to
be featured here in the next episode of
ask IJ just leave a comment below make
it creative you could even just say
Justine put me in a future episode of
ask IJ and you can look for yourself
here alright guys that's it for this
episode of ask I do thank you for
watching don't forget to subscribe so
you'll know what I post a new video be
sure to check out the last video
and if you're really that bored I have a
couple of the YouTube channels feel free
to check those out as well I'm gonna go
I love you guys and I'll see you well
when I see you
[Music]